sir a master bath though he was only a
little master owner but a master of his
craft and he was he was like that if you
worked with him I did quite a few things
in Rory and he was he was wonderful to
work with you know you you just felt so
close and you're right about his timing
his timing was him back unit and a
dapper little man - what a devil were
always looked whenever you saw him
anywhere he always took a lot of pride
about his appearance and like his timing
with with comedies just top rate top
rate its interests you mentioned that
actually I hadn't thought of that before
but every time Ronnie Corbett appeared
whether it was on a game show or as a
guest on somebody else's chat show or in
a sketch you always noticed what he was
wearing and he soon had two things he
had that smile that was clearly genuine
and always looking as if he was ready
for work that day oh yes and those
flashy ties used to wear and socks
although he was he was a character in so
many ways and was himself all-time you
never you know never saw bodies trying
to be somebody else so that he was
Ronnie Corbett soon as you got me when
you just think about him you can see his
smile even see a jacket or somebody was
wearing it he was he was that on the
golf courses when we leave he was always
very smart and looked look apart so he
looked the part all the time whenever
you met him was that the sign of a man
who took his took his life and took his
work seriously but didn't take himself
seriously
oh yes exactly you get it there he took
himself no because he was always making
remarks about himself not only is that
is
the size of him but otherwise he would
he would make remarks about himself that
were always in comedy he was always he
was always on if you know what I mean he
never sort of tried to to do anything
the only you can sees is a little smile
I'm watching the television the moment
and you see that face oh yeah how can
that be anybody else right Rami was just
a great big hole he's been left in show
business
we no longer have him that ability said
that ability Subarus to take on any
scripts to take on any task that sort of
pedigree of entertainment almost
vaudeville skills that you are part of
as well and many others were in their
time that abilities to relate to an
audience deliver what the production
required and keep the relationship with
the audience as the mainstay of any
performance that's the kind of multi
skilling that we don't see so much on TV
today know even though you don't under
you say ronnie was what it was just like
that here as I always say you know it
was an audience they can be half your
act in factor the best part of Iraq
sometimes and he was right there he had
great what I always loved about the
comic like Ronnie's great contacts
contact with the people he's
entertaining and you feel is doing it
just for you and that is a great contact
mister it's a great skill he had and I
just can't believe it he said that he's
gone and no longer with it no and so
many modern younger generation comics
like Ricky Gervais and all the rest
who've had him as guests on their shows
have written parts for him in sketches
that they put together Harry Enfield
they recognize his abilities in their
application for the modern world
and of course they're all missing too of
course they were of course Abel and he's
always spitting he was very very
adaptable you could put her on it with
anybody and give him a script if it was
a good script ''tis he's often I'm sure
otter a few lines here and there to make
me more him but no adaptability is is so
important in our business and Ronny has
that as well he's also one of the few
people who flourished being the straight
guy in a partnership he didn't get
eclipsed by the partner he actually kept
his own career going as well oh yeah oh
yeah no easy he was there a lot the two
Rorie's pick somebody's talking earlier
on about him on the other radiographers
in liver saying you know he was a bit of
a straight man but I disagree with that
completely Ronny was just as funny as
Ronnie vodka all the time and chanting
baby was pavia they never they never
that was a partnership and that's how
they treated one another with great
respect does it meet you pause as well
and look back at your own career so
bruce says tracking alongside so much of
what the Two Ronnies and so many others
were doing over all those years yes very
much so because we were different
entertainers then I think it was because
of the times we were living in and you
know we were used to work into family
audiences
whereas comedians today has to do a lot
of these comedy clubs that have to be
much more aggressive there has to be a I
don't know it is when you're working to
family audiences you do have that family
feeling and I think all of us at that
time had that feeling with an audience
which which was very nice it made you
feel part of a family and
think those wärtsilä kept us going aware
time and as long as you keep along with
the time this as well as you know so
instead of the don't suit works too it's
too hard at it and let your natural self
come through and this is what Ronnie had
he he had it in in spades he was it was
the lovely lovely man it's been hard to
talk about him actually because I can't
believe is gone as a result it you
coming on to talk about it so Bruce
thanks very much indeed for sharing your
thoughts with us on a difficult day and
we wish you all the best our selves in
the world all right thank you very much
bye-bye